what's up [__] i you thought i
was gonna keep your weight and whatnot
i've been busy you [__] but you
know i love you
i told you i'd check in with you once a
week
what time nobody [__] knows the only
thing is that i'm here
i stayed through my [__] word before
we even start this little tate that day
i want to tell you about the [__] uh
record albums i went and got this week
over at vintage rhino and uh
what the [__] woodbridge but listen
i'm toned up just like you guys i'm
saying
a couple edibles
oh these [__] pro tabs
tremendous it was a bag of 42 days ago
stop it you know what i'm saying tonight
was my
night i watched the town under the
khabib
then i went to a halloween party for my
daughter at a martial arts school
then we came back we hung out as a
family
and then we split chicken collards she
went to bed my wife got back
my wife went out for a drink got to get
him out from time to time if not they go
[__] nudge too young saying
but i just want to check in with you
guys i had a great week with you guys
i'm having a great time doing the
[__] album of the week
we picked up some new albums let me show
you what albums we got
just so you know when i'm [__] around
here you know what i'm saying
urban trees always representing big in
the [__] house
don't worry about none there's no coke
rocks in there those days are done
but check out what i got at vintage
vinyl
wood bridge [__] tremendous you
understand me
i opened it up with
one for the road let us skin it
tremendous
that live last live hour
opened up with another masterpiece you
may not agree with it
it's part of who the [__] i am that's
what it's all about right or wrong
who are you the [__] who are you
kidding me or what 20 of life no
[__] perot and then we had again you
know
all reliable
black sabbath never say die 1299 i gotta
do it you know what i'm saying
out of respect oh and i got the one to
[__] really
flip you [__] out ready
judas priest unleashed in the east
when we do that one i'll give you a
week's notice you get some [__]
heroin
and uh get ready to go i'm saying some
moxie pills whatever the [__] you doing
boogaloo pills
your real biscuits stop it now just
stick to the brief
that's all i could do that's a psa from
a joke
and look at this bad boy bad mother
finger
with [__] added extras the whole
thing so
listen y'all
it's gonna be alive and kicking it's
not what the [__] you like it's how it
affected me
and [__] you know
you know what i'm saying what it did to
me at the time
maybe it was at a time when i was low
you know i
pretended to i got to get to pretend
this too they're with me when i was at
my lowest point in the [__] 94 you
say
what the [__] you think you're dealing
i'm happy you [__] suckers are up see i
caught you
the east coast is probably not be new
but the west coast is alive and kicking
ready to [__] [__] slap
[__]
that's what i'm talking about look at
this stuff
see i was supposed to give him back my
bullets
i went to three different places nobody
had it you know what
won't have to give me back my bullets
was this one anyway
and then [__] street survivors
then they died that's it but you know
what listen you guys know me
i'm not gonna show up here with a
[__] bb gun
with no bbs or what a pistol with no
pistol
we showed up with the [__] this is it
this is what [__] got chris christie
out of the
i'm hospital gonna find the [__]
lighter you know what i'm saying
but don't stand in check in with that
crowd source
we're gonna put 14 000 people on there
seven thousand and jump up and down
discrimination we can't do it
this everybody gets the flavor everybody
gets a taste i don't care if you paid
three or fifteen you know what
you've been with me since day one that's
all that [__] matters
i put a little music on but listen don't
take it off
i [__] around you were just gonna watch
some white game maybe throwing the last
bet i don't know what the [__] you doing
but
i figured it's always a good time to
check in with my [__] soldiers
make sure i love you make sure you
understand the tier system
the fifteen dollars gets the whole
package plus
you get a [__] uh shirt once they
come out which i'm
doubling up on this week you know they
only wanted to do xl and xl double what
the [__] is wrong with you i got some
fat [__] out here
that need [__] double xl chip like
salad maybe a medium
we're gonna have you covered
uncle joe don't [__] around yeah i used
to be a deeper if i'm gonna rob you i'm
gonna rob you with a gun you know what
i'm saying i ain't gonna [__] rob
your red t-shirt
you guys have been there since day one
notice the people i talked to they've
been there since day one so i don't [__]
around
but i did my usual ritual
i'll give you a cake emote you put a cup
under your tongue
night night i read give me a bottle now
i go upstairs i put on an episode of
something
next you know extreme the [__]
morning i'm sitting there
my back's all stiff i need 18
chiropractors but who gives a [__]
it puts me down
you mean it'll go out of health
this is two milligrams of thc but five
or six is cbdn
cbn and that's the [__] that really
takes you to the next level
if you need extra you take the kiko mold
tablets
now tonight i took a moat
but before i got the party started i did
six [__] protabs
just you know it's sad you gotta
celebrate whether you're by yourself
with your deaf grandmother what the [__]
are you gonna do you i'm saying
what do you wanna do you wanna start a
war here
you wanna keep your head together which
is the most important thing during this
whole [__] pandemic
is keeping your [__] head
together it's that simple
whether you win or you're [__] out
you gotta keep your [__] head
together
things are gonna not want your own way
you're gonna wake up there's gonna be a
flat
you're gonna get laid off unemployment
blow a finger up your [__] ass who
gets this [__]
you know what you're gonna move forward
eric wrote you had a birthday the other
night my buddy
he's gay but it's got nothing to do with
it some guy blew a [__] candle out in
his [__] that's a birthday he said
you [__] sit at home happy
birthday with a
cake and everybody comes home we'll get
a [__]
you want to get the party started
see oh no have been
here downloaded queer everybody's asleep
everybody's napping no no i got the
dodgers on upstairs
but i figured i'd take a breather
checking with you [__] animals to let
you know i love you
you may not think i love you but i love
you to death well
if you get the crown silence they can't
put it back i don't give a [__]
just don't be a jack off and try to put
[__] [__] up as your own
and then you don't think my management's
got to take down your [__] i don't need
this [__] my life
i try to keep it simple guys you know
what i'm saying you autographed
[__] where you were when you
went last time i gave an autograph
i bought a [__] rv i don't know i
tell you the story on some of this
podcast
but i'm here now and i want to come up
to you and tell you i love you i miss
you
without you guys i'd have [__] got
we're helping some people
and that's all that matters and we're
getting started
together like [__] family you know
i'm saying some people eat
italian meatballs on saturdays uncle
joey gets stoned with his [__] family
on saturdays
like that there's no misunderstandings i
don't wanna you know [__]
enjoy it and do the crowd cast this is
it this is for everybody
i'm gonna isolate you [__] what
time of what type of [__] will i
be
you got the three dollar tier you got
everything except no messages
dollar t you get going right into three
dollar t your final t
you get the dmv section don't ask me
what i'm smoking
let me know about your problems your
grandmother's eyeball fell out let's get
some crazy glue
and let's put it back in action you know
what i'm saying ten dollar tear
you get the uh the album of the week and
the fifteen dollar t you get the merch
when it comes out
they're talking about january and i
gotta talk to these people
we're gonna rush this [__] up all sizes
hoodies
baseball caps [__] condoms whatever
you need
we're gonna come out with your uncle
joey's joint don't miss this week's
podcast
i'm gonna get to the root of addiction
and what sows it like this
like that you go to 20 rehabs you spend
that afternoon with me
i'll put you on the deutsche chamber of
death eyes if you're hearing noises
and then that's it what the [__] else
you want
i checked in it's sunday night saturday
night i love you [__] with all
my heart
you're probably about to survive who's
on saturday night live tonight who gives
a [__]
who gives a [__] you're gonna sit there
and watch that comedy's propaganda
listen i know commies when i see him you
understand me
the comments are trying to take over i'm
here to tell you
don't believe the hype [__] it but pe 80
[__] nine
don't believe the hype maybe 88 i was
doing time what do i know
what am i [__] wikipedia i'm just
trying to [__] do what you guys are
doing
put the pieces together step by step one
day at a time one day anytime i get
better i get more comfortable
wednesday night vinnie's my last one for
two weeks
i gotta shoot a couple of things i'm
doing yeah there's papa's his podcast
uh mercy has the weak wealth from school
i can't just dump it on my wife
you know what is that life has taken
over
but we still keep pushing i know you
guys are [__] going through whatever
you're going through listen
time will pass i was in that rocket ship
thinking i was gonna die and here we are
26 years later talking on some [__]
satellite that the fbi is watching
and we're here we are pilot the
bombardier [__] you know what i'm
saying
pilot the bombardier so you do what you
need to do
i'll do what i need to do enough is
enough [__] you're not going to
sit there no more
there's your uncle joey talking to you
you're going to go out there to be the
best you can be
every [__] weekend if you [__] up and
do an oxycontin what do you want me to
tell you
hit a meeting take your sponsor out for
lunch buy him a [__] danish
and start from scratch and if you do it
again do the same thing and eventually
you keep buying that [__] in
danish
and you'll get off the [__] pills
just smoke reefer right
it takes you to that dangerous side but
it doesn't you go home
you eat a piece of cheesecake and you
fall asleep on the couch drooling like i
have to rethought
who's better than you you're going to be
eating that [__] now at this age
and ruin everything for everybody you
know next step
you're out there [__] patterson
babanya
and who needs that [__] once you get on
the babana they ain't no coming back
how do i know i was there i didn't pop
the needles
i snorted the coconut the hammer was not
bad
but that was then this is now we change
every seven years
obviously from looking at me you can
tell i've changed
in just a short time that we've been
here
i don't want to be a comic i don't want
to be a [__] book
i don't want to jump up and down all i
want to be is be a dad
be part of the community and then we'll
take it from there
by the way i love benny's comedy club
and i'm gonna tell you why he gives a
[__]
a lot of these comments are telling you
to put 150 in there and you get there
they put 190 200 people
you're starting a copic convention
that's a cavodio situation
38. no close contact no uh handshakes no
headshots
we'll make it through we'll double it up
the 50
then that the party started for december
you know what i'm saying
right now i'm just trying to get my
material order
uncle joey's joining and make you guys
proud on patreon that's all i'm trying
to do everything else is background
music talk to me
trust me when i tell you you patreon
[__] have done more
more for me when i answer those messages
when i read the comments from your posts
it brought me up when i first got here i
was down i went to patreon then you
[__] were
at attention that means the world to me
guys so thank you very much
you know my heart stands you know you
all get a message even though you paid a
dollar you
[__] [__] suckers you know i love you
too much but eventually
patreon's gonna take it down so but i
love you guys
you go up to three dollars you get some
love from uncle joey you get a daily
lens
you get the [__] joey diaz project
different perspective that what i'm
doing on the regular projects
podcast and most importantly
who's the best psychiatrist for 60
dollars a year than uncle joey
don't hit me up with though what we just
smoking hit me up with your problem
watch me bam cut it in half
and next thing you know you're jumping
up and down like a half a [__] on the
[__] factory you know what i'm saying
that's it and that's that i love you
dudes
at the end i might [__]
up because i don't know how to turn this
off but
who gives a [__] you know what matters
we had to stein
we got to spend some time together
just to have a laugh or sing a song
but before we know it who the [__] knows
the rest of the lyrics i was looking
that's carol but
comes the time we have to say
so long
and that's it i'm gonna have to put on
my glasses because you know i'm gonna
[__]
but besides that i'm with your
[__] you don't say
i'm pretty [__] stoned till you
[__] push me over the end
i'm gonna have to drink some water and
sit there and make believe
i know somebody i'm talking about
[__] up let's see what this is
no that one's not it
so i think this is it boom boom boom
there's a picture there you go that's a
picture of us right there
looking good like a [__]
you